hey youtube I have a really important
announcement to make
it's nothing you're gonna shave your
beard is it no it is way bigger than
that
roll sound
I'm here at the Olympic Cauldron in
Vancouver as you know I've been
traveling for a long time I left Sydney
I came to Vancouver went to Detroit New
York that Chi Liberty Toronto Waterloo
where I was mobbed by a fan then LA for
VidCon San Francisco and now back in
Vancouver but this is only the start of
the journey I am leading a team of
youtubers and I'm heading to London for
the 2012 Olympic Games now this team you
have to meet them they're extraordinary
people from Brisbane we have Ellie oh
hey there my name is Ellie I'm from app
shadowmen go geek and awesome person
from Tasmania we have the archer Erica
in the air now one of the rules is you
always need an archer no matter what
kind of team you're putting together
always comes in handy you've seen the
Avengers okay and from pert we have
these guys how ridiculous we did trick
shots and 30 so if you're inspired by
the games and you want to work out you
got to check them out because they've
got all the best olympic-themed workouts
and finally we have a little channel
called minutephysics you may have heard
of it it's a dictatorship universe you
decide how you work and I get no vote I
would complain except that I do get to
decide where to stick my nose and which
questions to ask so that is team record
gold over the next few weeks we're all
going to be doing content themed around
the Olympics so subscribe to all the
channels so you can find out what
they're doing I'm going to be doing the
science of sport and the science in and
around London so stay tuned for that and
I will see you in London
[Music]
oh yeah and I'm gonna shave off my beard
so there you have it are you regretting
this now yeah just a little bit yeah
that's what I thought it'll grow back oh
and one more thing it's become clear to
me that it's quite difficult to make
videos about science while traveling
while I'm on the road and so I apologize
to those of you who've been looking for
a really hardcore science content but
I'm gonna kick it up a notch and to
separate out the non science things I'm
starting a second channel called to
veritasium so that's like an isotope
where I can just communicate with you
respond to comments and and do things
that are just more off-the-cuff and let
you know what's going on so if you want
to watch me say climb a headless Ice
Bear then then click the link that's
weird